this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah thanks a lot for the introduction
and it's um it's really great to be here
I get to be here given a seminar and so
I'm going to focus mostly on phosphorus
I think in my abstract I had listed
nitrogen as well and I was hoping to
bring in some of the work that we're
doing on nitrogen but i just recently
gave a talk at the symposium on
phosphorus that was in down in Annapolis
just a couple months ago and so I kind
of built my talk around that one kind of
expanded a little bit so i think i'm
going to spend most of my time talking
about phosphorus and the role of
hydrology and connecting phosphorus
sources on the landscape to receiving
waters and it's going to be a tour of
the Chesapeake Bay and mostly allow the
research we're doing and then
highlighting scene of some research from
others that kind of helps to tell the
story so I've kind of I've broken this
presentation out into four parts
starting with kind of the sloped upland
regions of the Chesapeake Bay focusing
on some issues and the coastal plain
lowlands mostly on the Delmarva
Peninsula where we do a lot of work or
artificial drainage is it kind of as a
primary concern streams and rivers so
just the connectivity that occurs you
know in streams and rivers moving
nutrients moving phosphorous you know to
downstream receiving it waters and then
emerging concerns just some things I see
it's kind of emerging concerns and
nutrient management you know that we
should probably paying attention to in
the future so I'm going to start with an
area that I know really well I see Todd
Walters here he's probably seen so many
slides before but we do a lot of work on
variable sorcerer area hydrology as does
the many groups as do many groups here
at Cornell and so a lot of people
contributed to the kind of the ideas on
the role of variable sorcery hydrology
and connecting nutrient sources with
receiving waters here's Cornell this is
where we are now just outside of the
Chesapeake Bay I do a lot of work at the
mantengo Creek experimental watersheds
mostly this little 7.3 square kilometer
watershed known as w38 it's kind of a
colloquial name but we have a gridded
system that you know names our watershed
so it was kind of an interesting name
and there are two sub catchments and w38
a bit of experimental work one's ft 36
which I'll refer to a little bit later
and one is Matt earned its 11 hectare
experimental watershed or we've done
some work on variable sources hydrology
and nutrient loss and so we have kind of
you know two different kinds of soil
conditions in this watershed we have
upland soils here that lack say some
kind of a discontinuity in soils that
would purchase water so they're
well-drained soils that don't have a
fragile an and then here in these lower
landscape positions we have grabbed pins
and they were basically impede vertical
movement of water and will perch water
and will create areas of saturation and
it's kind of this highlights you can see
the nature of these well-drained soils
and compare them you know to the poorly
drained soils that we find here and we
go out we send technicians we've done
this quite a bit over the years kind of
a very low-tech technique for looking at
areas of saturation and landscape we
call it the wet boot or you've probably
see in the literature even as the
squishy boot technique honestly there
are papers published with that in the
title out of Europe especially they
tried to actually quantitate this method
but anyway so you know we'll go out
seasonally and just find areas of
saturation and take a GPS unit and
essentially map them you know so you can
see here in august of 2003 for example
you know the location of some saturated
areas these are disconnected section or
saturated area so assuming they didn't
you know you know change over time with
any kind of rainfall event they're
unlikely to connect to the stream but
you could compare that to something
later in the fall after we've had a
chance to Wed up a bit you know the
saturated air is expand quite a bit and
now these are connected to this little
ephemeral stream here so any nutrient
loss that occurs in these zones would be
a risk to water quality there's two
types of runoff generate generation
mechanisms that were concerned with
largely you know infiltration excess
runoff in these zones where we have
well-drained soils where you know
basically it takes a pretty extreme
rainfall like a thunderstorm or high
intensity rain to exceed the
infiltration capacity of the soils in to
generate runoff and it can contrast that
against you know we normally see in
these zones which is kind of a perched
saturation excess runoff phenomenon
where these soils are saturated and any
excess rainfall runs off and they're
also close to the street
so there's an increased risk of runoff
connecting to the stream and then
nutrient loss so if we zoom in on this
hill slope here we've done years of you
know plot scale runoff monitoring at
these sites and so these are just totals
for about three years of monitoring it's
a two thousand two two two thousand four
I think and so you can see most of what
we're generating must have run off
that's being generated in these
well-drained soils here is infiltration
excess runoff and largely at the lower
landscape position its saturation excess
ronto we're using shallow wells and
looking at the status of the water table
and also soil moisture sensors to infer
these runoff generation mechanisms but
you know over this time period most of
what we get down here is is saturation
excess run out these are largely
saturated areas for large parts of the
year and then the management that's
imposed on this landscape you can see
that the trends in soil phosphorus
moving up the slope here at the lower
landscape position we're just above
agronomic optimum in terms of soil
phosphorus concentrations about 78 parts
per million that's just above what's
needed to grow crops but if you move up
the slope you know where we're receiving
more repeated applications of semen or
fertilizer we've had much higher so
phosphorus concentrations and so if you
just relate those soil phosphorus
concentrations to the dissolve
phosphorus concentrations in runoff you
get a you know increasing amounts of
dissolve p and run off with higher soil
phosphorus concentrations and that's its
relationships have been shown over and
over in the literature but just because
we know that doesn't mean that we can
necessarily predict the load the load is
driven by the amount of runoff that's
generated from a particular zone and so
we look at the loads that we get from
these regions it's really this region
here just because of its high hot large
amounts of runoff there Jenna the high
volumes of runoff that we get those are
the where we see the high loads and so
these are areas of the landscape that we
call critical source areas or
hydrologically sensitive areas that go
by lots of names but essentially the
same thing you know where you have a
source and a transport mechanism and
it's in proxy it's close to the stream
and so you there's a higher risk of
phosphorus loss from these regions of
the landscape so we've done some extra
work looking at you know though these
zones of saturation this is
work that Mark Williams who was a PhD
student at Penn State was doing well
first I'll just back up and just show
that you know these are kind of another
look at these variable variably
saturated areas in the landscape but
mark came in he set up a network of
azama ters in these saturated areas and
this is the FD 36 watershed just north
of mattern also within the kind of man
tanker creep experimental watersheds and
we used electrical resistivity imaging
to try to understand a little bit about
the subsurface connectivity that we have
you know what maintains saturation in
these in these portions of the landscape
and so it's kind of fortuitous because
we didn't do it for all that long as
we're only able to do it for one season
essentially what you do is use you use
electrodes in a transect here and you're
basically sending electric pulses and
measuring you know certain between
current electrodes and potential
electrodes and your changes in
resistivity can be used to infer changes
in soil moisture content it's also
sensitive to changes in soil temperature
and to any kind of conductive solution
but if you can control for the other
things that affect it you can infer that
you know what we're seeing is really due
to changes in saturation and so we did
some monitoring over a series of storm
events that weight up the landscape and
so you can see here you know these are
the where you see decreased resist
resist Iffat e here and we know that we
have a fragile pan just about 60
centimeters below the surface you can
see that boundary really clearly so that
in we're kind of concluding from this is
that this is the perch water that's
sitting above the proj Japan this is an
area without a groundwater seat and then
we're comparing it to this zone here we
have active seepage going on and so when
you look at the area where we have is
seep we have upwelling water you can see
kind of a increased upward gradient of
groundwater and we can infer this from
the Kazama ters that we have here we
have vomit errs at different depths that
allow us to look at gradients of water
movement and we see evidence for you
know the saturated this connected
saturated area here which you know when
you compare it when we can combine it
with this evidence it suggested this is
an area of upwelling water and seepage
that we see in these zones and this is a
video that I'm not sure if I'll be able
to get to play but this is taking
during after a fairly large storm event
in this seepage zone you can see the
kind of see if it works sometimes these
things don't work and of course it yeah
it will alright so that's kind of what
you see this is after I think this is
after Tropical Storm Lee so when we had
this is a huge amount of rain it took to
cause that kind of but so if the ER I
it's kind of valuable because it allows
you to as they say visualize I mean you
can get quantitative information to
commit to and I'll show you some more
work we're doing with electrical
resistivity imaging later but that was
just some work looking at just trying to
get at the saturated or these you know
areas of connectivity that you can see
from with soil moisture so subsurface
foster's transport is kind of an
oft-overlooked pathway a lot of it you
know a lot of the literature you know
over time has suggested most of the
phosphorus in moving overland flow but
we also see a lot moving in subsurface
flow and so we've done work on a small
dairy farm in the Allegheny plateau
region and this is Pete Kleinman's work
where we were monitoring a spring house
so this is that this is receiving
subsurface flows from up there's fields
above here that would be to recharge
area for the spring but it's also where
a lot of ignores applies as a dairy farm
so they're getting pretty frequent
regular applications of dairy manure
this is the home here so this spring
house used to serve water for the home
it does it doesn't any longer but they
actually helped us do some monitoring
they were collecting samples from the
springhouse over time and then keeping
track of women or was being applied to
the fields in the upgrading zone above
the springhouse and so you can see you
know these are the days that minorities
are the you know it's kind of applied
spring and fall so april-october and use
of the times of manure application and
here's the trace of dissolved phosphorus
in the spring house and so you can see
soon after manures applied you tend to
get a spike get a pretty significant
spike here and dissolve phosphorus and
and you know smaller one here and
another one here so it's responding
pretty quickly to the timing of an or
application and you get these subsurface
transfers of 50 phosphorus
you know so it's it's not just an
Overland flow problem it's also a
subsurface transport problem things you
can do to mitigate that include just
simple tillage so it's but this is
especially problematic where we have no
till and you get a lot of soil
development at macropore formation you
can come in with frequent tillage and
break up the macro pores and the macro
pores or what's you know serving as the
you know one form of kind of rapid
connectivity between the surface and the
subsurface and so one management tool is
just too till and you can see here just
by telling you can reduce you know the
amount of dissolved phosphorous and
leachate relative to if you just
broadcast on the surface and it can
connect to subsurface flow pathways and
so those are some things you can do to
get at reducing subsurface transfers
okay another common problem and Briggs
is kind of low hanging fruit stuff but
another common problem that we see you
know this is some work we're doing on
the Piedmont is just barnyard runoff
from animal heavy heavy you serious so I
mean these are the kinds of you know
these plant a lot of plain SEC farms
down the Piedmont region this is ammon
or just spilled manure here in the
barnyard area i mean just real simple
things but but cause a major water
quality problem and so this used some
photos of kind of the condition of the
buff some of these barnyards that you
see lots of trampled you know animal
heavy use area so this is all compacted
soil and i get a lot of runoff just from
the bar and it's from the rubes and
these are impervious surface so you get
a lot of runoff from these zones and so
we've been monitoring with flumes just
the amount of runoff that we get off
these barnyards and also the quality to
water and so just in this small area
we're generating a more of 20 kilograms
of phosphorous per year now the size of
the barnyard really small so if you
actually scaled that to a leica
kilograms per hectare per year that the
numbers astronomical it seems almost
unfair to report something so high but
you get fairly substantial phosphorous
losses from these barnyards and then
what you have is basically you know
either some kind of rapid connection
like a gully in this case here so I mean
that water just hits that gully and goes
right down to a stream
and so we've been working actually with
some kind of fancy filtration
technologies to try to deal with this
it's one approach so we're routing water
into these you know based agregame
inlets and it's moving in to a fairly
sophisticated system that's supposed to
get at not only nitrogen removal but
also phosphorus removal this is
Alexandra trees el Renza she's been
experimenting a lot from with
phosphorous filtration devices at the
University of Vermont and so this is one
of her filters using I think iron slag
as the medium for phosphorus removal and
so these things work when the flows are
low but when you get fairly large storms
they get overwhelmed and so you're
asking a lot of us of a system like this
to filter the shear volumes of water
that are being generated from this kind
of an operation and so what we found is
that probably what's neat is just better
water management like gutters and things
on the roofs and keeping the clean water
clean and separating out water from the
dirty water and then just trying to
treat smaller volumes of the really bad
stuff because this this gets clogged up
with sediment it gets clogged up with
manure it's interesting to look at but
it we've had all kinds of problems with
it under big storms it just
underperforms but so there's a role for
these things I think but water
management and just reducing the volumes
of water coming off some of these sites
is kind of a low-hanging fruit that I
think and I would be would be beneficial
so kind of shifting gears a little bit
moving from the sloped areas down into
the coastal plain we do a lot of work at
the university of maryland eastern
shores is on the Delmarva Peninsula so
this is the manoukian River watershed
here and here is the University of
Maryland Eastern Shore within the
manoukian we see some pretty extreme
phosphorous losses in artificial
drainage at these sites anywhere from
two kilograms per hectare per year all
the way up to over 20 in some cases from
some of the ditches on the Eastern Shore
and so that's kind of the main issue is
the role of artificial drainage and
basically connecting phosphorous sources
to receiving waters and so drainage is
really critical in these flat landscapes
they use it
lower water tables lower lower them
below the routing zone so they can grow
crops and that there's also they can get
equipment out there but when you do that
just the act of putting it a ditch or
putting in a tile you lower the water
table you increase the travel time of
water in the system it also increases
connectivity dig that digiti / and
that's that's kind of an act of
intensifying the drainage of the system
and so another way is to kind of two
ways to intensify the drainage one is to
is to dig the ditch deeper or to have
the tile installed in a deeper depth but
also spacing plays a role so the more
closely spaced the ditches are the tiles
are the more intense the drainage is
another way to look at that is just in
terms of drainage density and so it's
kind of like a watershed hydrology
approach where you just look at the
length of the channels in the system
divided by the area and a lot of folks
have kind of looked at it this way and
so in this case here you have a 27-acre
field and these are the existing ditches
in the field here and so if you
calculate the drainage density you know
based on the area the field on the
length of ditches it's about point O 2
meters to the negative 1 the critical
source areas of phosphorous contribution
to these ditches are largely pretty
close to the ditch there within five or
ten meters or so and some of this
evidence is from tracer studies that
have been done elsewhere just looking at
you know where's the contributing area
that the kind of the annual you know
contributing area to these ditches if
you intensify the drainage which is
going on quite a bit on the Eastern
Shore in other words if you just add
more tiles or more ditches to the system
basically you've just increased not only
the connectivity of the system but also
oops back up sick but just you know you
mean increase the contribution of
phosphorous from areas that we're not
you know initially connected now they
are connected you're connecting new
phosphorous sources to drainage and more
rapidly removing water from the system
and so you've just increased the spatial
coverage of critical source areas across
the basin I know a lot of works been
done here at Cornell looking at road
side ditches and so this is kind of a
similar thing you're just increasing the
artificial connectivity the system and
more rapidly delivering nutrients to
streams and so this is
this is the ditch drain a tragar
cultures a problem but there's also the
roadside you know ditch problem that I
know it's been quite a lot of workman's
done here looking at that issue Keith
shilling in the Midwest did some really
interesting work just looking at the
role of drainage density increasing the
density of drainage on travel times and
basically showed that there's an
exponential relationship between the
mean travel time in years and the
drainage density of artificial drainage
of either tiles or ditches and so you
can see you know at first if you start
to rapidly increase the density of
drainage there's a pretty steep drop-off
but then it levels off to a point where
you can keep adding tiles to keep adding
[ __ ] and there's not much you know
change in travel time but it's a pretty
steep drop in travel time you know say
15 years or so from you know just this
you know from going point I'll 12 point
02 so you can change the travel times
more rapidly move water off the site but
that's also a problem for you know
phosphorus pollution and nitrogen
pollution as well these are some data
from Kevin king in the Midwest just
showing how quickly phosphorus responds
and tile drainage and so it's slicker
than you get these really rapid
responses you know where you get up tix
inflow and then phosphorous responds
right away so it just suggest very fast
delivery of phosphorus to the system and
so if you combine that with evidence
from Marty ship otello I the usda-ars
and others have done this to where
they've taken smoke machines and just
blown smoke up the tie lines to find
macropores and soils and it just shows
how well connected these tiles are to
these you know small these macropores
systems that form in especially no-till
soils and so you just have rapid
conveyance of phosphorous either in
manure or soil phosphorus and it gets
delivered straight down the macropores
into the tiles and see a very rapid
delivery of phosphorous out of these
tiles and so it's a common problem in
the Midwest and it's in part
contributing to the lake erie situation
that you've probably all heard about the
toxic algal blooms a lot of that
phosphorous delivery is in part being
contributed by the tile drainage is
there and the rapid expansion and
intensification of tile drainage that's
going on throughout the Midwest
back on the kind of the coastal plain we
see very similar kind of response in our
ditches so you see you know very large
storm event here in one of our field
ditches in a very rapid response you
know in phosphorus concentrations really
rapid rise right with it timed with the
peak of the hydrograph it's about you
know one point five milligrams per liter
so it suggests very you know fast flow
pass it peeks early in the hydrograph
and we've looked you know across the
landscape you know some there's been
some suggestion that no groundwater is
playing a big role and so we we have a
lot of wells say and these are that this
is actually the ditch this is this ditch
right here that goes to this field so we
have on just a dense network of shallow
wells measuring the kind of groundwater
concentrations of phosphorus in the
system and if you look you know they're
on the order of you know at the most
maybe point three milligrams per liter
on average this is kind of collecting
data once every two weeks throughout the
year and end of the mean is more on the
order of point 05 and so if you just
think about this in a mixing model
context as this being one of your end
members of phosphorus it's unlikely that
groundwater is you know alone you know
is the big source even though these
ditches are largely draining the
groundwater system so there has to be
another source that's contributing to
these fairly high peaks of phosphorus
that we routinely see about 1.5 up to
sometimes two or three milligrams per
liter in these storm events and so work
that Pete bodice who was with a or he
was with our group for allows a postdoc
but now he's in the you know at the
Wisconsin ARS unit he had a network of
shallow wells installed at different
depths throughout the site and what you
see is that there's a shallow either a
perch system or preferential flow
pathways that rapid to rapidly deliver
very high concentrations of phosphorous
sometimes in order of 10 parts per
million or more you know in the upper
foot upper foot and a half say of soil
that's either get these high water
tables in the spring that form so March
April right now the water table down at
the University of Malaysian Shores
probably within a foot of the surface
and so you get these storm events that
just move water very rapidly and they
tend to have very high concentrations of
phosphorous and that's most likely what
we believe is this is the contributing
source of phosphorus that's where your
highest fostering phosphorus
concentrations
so I'll are usually in the upper foot so
we have concentrations of say 300 parts
per million in that upper foot so that's
essentially where we see most of the
phosphorus moving so the opie climbing's
done some work down on at umes and it's
kind of a mass balance approach where we
had edged your field flumes looking at
the volume of water and overland flow
and the cotton you know that the loads
that were being delivered and also you
can measure the loads in the ditch and
by difference you can infer that almost
ninety two percent of the Fosters is
probably moving in the subsurface that's
kind of just a mass balance look at it
and just based on some other evidence
you know we're inferring that you know
the most the riskiest sources for
phosphorus delivery to these ditches is
probably within five to ten meters of
the ditch and as you move further away
the travel times are long and it's
unlikely that they're contributing much
least on a kind of a regular basis to
these ditches so we've gone in we're
planning to go in and do some electrical
resistivity imaging at these sites too
because we're interested in trying to
understand more about these shallow
subsurface flow pathways that are active
and so here we're going in with tracers
and using the electrical resistivity
imaging and the tracers to tell us
something about shallow subsurface flow
pathways so this is just a test study
really we didn't we intend to do this
under storm conditions but here we're
just kind of testing it out just to make
sure we know what we're doing we're
working with the team from Rutgers to do
this and so this is ray bryant actually
so array was here at cornell for for a
good part of its career he's now working
with us at ARS he's spraying a
concentrated salt solution about five
millisiemens per centimeter so of just
sodium chloride on to this plot here and
we also are injecting the solution into
wells we're just trying to get a
response basically just to see if the ER
is can tell us anything about movement
of water and so we're spraying that and
we're basically doing time-lapse ERI
collecting these images of resistivity
and you can see you know these areas of
lower resistivity this is where your
highly conductive solution is starting
to infiltrate and starting to move you
know and you can kind of look at it over
time you're taking these different
time-lapse images
you can just see the advancement of
assault plume you know in the sub
service so we want to understand a
little bit what would mean the goal is
really I understand you know how these
subsurface flow pathways develop how
long does it take them to get from the
field to the ditch and you can actually
get I mean the images are nice you can
get them you can do 3d mountain you know
videos of these things of the salt
tracers but you can actually derive
quantitative information from the
time-lapse ERI and so we're interested
in understanding more about the
hydraulics of the system so that you
know the conductivity of the soils the
travel times and some of the other
quantitative hydrologic information you
can get from these kinds of images and
so we plan to go out this spring we hope
and inject tracers and do it under storm
conditions when we expect these shallow
flow pathways to be active and to track
them and based on some kind of advanced
modeling that we've been doing we expect
to have to do this over a series of
storms and we thought maybe one storm
will be enough to just move it from the
field to the ditch but it turns out that
the travel times are quite slow even
just within five or ten meters of the
ditch you're talking tens of days too or
longer you know for some of this stuff
to potentially move so we could be
looking at probably weeks and weeks of
time-lapse imaging to try to see how
long it takes you know the salt to move
and also where it's moving and that
might tell us a little bit something
about the pathways are active it might
be also moving phosphorus from the field
to the ditch there's an issue of
infrastructure intensification on the
Eastern Shore so just basically real
simple things like that poultry industry
on the Eastern Shore is concentrating
and so you're there constructing a lot
of what they call these zero acre farms
where it's just poultry litter sheds
they're not growing crops they're just
producing poultry and producing a lot of
manure and so you know you take a site
like this where this is a kind of a
before picture of the but you know using
the curb number kind of the amount of
runoff you had a stormwater you would
generate on a site and now you know you
add for 600 foot by 66-foot poultry
Barnes you've jacked up probably just
because of the you know impervious
surface generate you know from the barns
you know forty percent increase in the
amount of runoff that runoff has to go
somewhere so you have you know these
ditches you know that are probably going
to convey more flow and probably
increase the loads of a phosphorus and
in a landscape that's already phosphorus
saturated so this kind of
intensification is going on quite a bit
you know the more we drive down to the
UM yes we always see new areas of barns
going up so and there's the issues that
you know that we're concerned about is
just water management just in and around
the barn so this is an example just from
UMES where I mean they have these kinds
of water management problems where you
just have a lot of water coming off the
barn and actually there was this
particular practice with subsidized by
the state of Maryland it's not
performing all that well and the
consequences of that are it's let me
back up this here is what you'll see is
ditch 8 it's also the ditch that is
responsible for about 20-some 25 or so
kilograms per hectare per year of
phosphorus loss just in that ditch alone
and it's because it's this is the shed
that was Dripping all that water and it
also has a it's a pole trailer storage
said so it's just these low hanging
fruit kind of problems where you if you
do a better job managing the water you
hopefully could do a better job at least
reducing these just substantially high
losses of phosphorus that we get so I'll
say a little bit about in-stream
processes because there's been quite a
bit of work done just trying to
understand phosphorus movement in
streams most of what we do you know we
kind of we do work could say one scale
it's a like a hill slope scale you know
we may be monitoring also at the small
watershed scale also maybe at a large so
these are kind of a nested watershed
kind of approach but we're really
interested in what you know what's going
on how these connect how these different
scales connect and what's going on in
the streams to help move phosphorus and
so this is some work that rich McDowell
did with Andrew sharply in the FG
thirty-six watershed just looking at you
know the different controls of base flow
and storm flow on phosphorus movement in
streams and so here you see phosphorus
concentrations at four different flumes
in FG thirty-six and base flow the
concentrations tend to increase and this
has been attributed just do the you know
the sorption capacity of the stream
sediments high capacity to desorb
phosphorous here and decreasing capacity
as you move downstream
and you can contrast that with what you
see during storms where you have kind of
the opposite more of a dilution effect
basically as you go downstream so
phosphorus concentrations in stream
water tend to decline during storms
that's largely due to having kind of a
basically a critical source area
phosphorus loss here we have a lot of
runoff generation and high phosphorus
concentrations and soils and then that
signal kind of being deluded as you move
downstream but you know when you kind of
just consider whether the AP the annual
export patterns of phosphorus do in
streams most of our flows are you know
base flows ninety percent of the flow is
in any given year you know w38 would be
classified as base flow and maybe ten
percent of the flows you would classify
as as storm flows this is just you know
in terms of time just ten percent of
time we had storm flow but the annual
export you know it's largely driven by
storm plus so seventy percent of the
phosphorus loss is occurring in storms
and maybe the only thirty percent or so
in base flow so it's you know it's kind
of this unequal distribution of you know
foster slots recurring a small amount of
small portion of the time and it the
highest flows and there's an interesting
study you know so and a lot of that fun
a lot of that phosphorus losses
particulate too so it's it's moving you
know with with sediment so there was an
interesting study that came out and
water resources research from a group
led by I think pizzuto at a Delaware
looking at just how long does it take
it's a sediment and you know by you know
by extension there also including things
like particular phosphorus to move from
some of these watersheds say to the
Chesapeake Bay and so I just picked one
of the watersheds where they worked the
little conestoga Creek because it's in
the Chesapeake Bay and it's really
interesting because you know if you just
think of sediment transport you know and
this is a suspended sediment transport
it's pretty fast you know storms can
move it quite a distance but you know
they ransom you know theoretical
sediment transport models where they
actually tried to account for the role
of storage say in floodplains and other
areas of the stream system and it's
pretty fascinating amuse your
theoretical model so they still need to
be tested you know but it if you account
for the time spent in storage the time
average velocity of silt clay which is
probably the size fraction that's mostly
moving a lot of the particular p it's
about point two kilometers per year and
if you can just consider that you know
it's an 80 kilometers you know between
say that stream and the
out to the Chesapeake Bay you're looking
at you know greater than 600 years to
move phosphorus from that stream down to
the bay now this is you know based on
some modeling work and they're actually
going back and looking with different
kinds of tracers to corroborate what
their models suggest but it suggests
millennia in some of these for some of
these dreams to really move a lot of
that phosphorus it's just another one of
these system lags it's built you know
that's built in that you know so they're
looking at from the best management
practice standpoint if you put in BMPs
to control sediment and eroded
phosphorous loss how long is it going to
take before that signal propagates down
state to the bay and there you know
based on their work they're saying you
know many many decades to hundreds of
years or more before you might see some
of that so let's I just thought that was
kind of interesting there's a really big
issue that you've probably heard about
with the conowingo damn and so I thought
I'd touch on that a little bit here
specifically related to tropical storm
lee which is a huge storm that occurred
September 7 to the 15th and 2011 one of
the one of the bigger floods that we've
experienced in the Susquehanna drainage
so this just shows the kind of
accumulative precipitation that fell
across the region you know anywhere you
know six or eight inches or more of
rainfall and here you can see the
sediment plume inert you know that was
in response to that huge flood and this
is some work out of help from Bob Hirsch
USGS just showing the amount of
phosphorous that was lost in that one
single event and so here's the total
phosphorus loss 61 percent of the
phosphorus load in 2011 was attributed
to tropical storm lee so just so just
for one year sixty one percent a load
from one event as a percent as a
fraction of the last decade the last ten
years it was it accounted for twenty-two
percent of the phosphorus loss and this
is at conowingo this is where these data
are coming from and nine percent of the
loss over the last 35 years the period
of record that he looked at nineteen
seventy eight to twenty eleven and so
you know those of a cenar group and
elsewhere you know we've kind of been
calling Hana Wingo dam is like the
world's greatest BMP because it traps
set them into traps a lot of phosphorus
and it's kind of
you know this barrier between the
Susquehanna River and the Chesapeake Bay
downstream of it but perhaps it could be
considered one of the single greatest
sources of legacy phosphorous to the
Chesapeake Bay because you're getting
its capacity it's almost it's almost
reached capacity the sediment stored
behind the dam it's become almost kind
of a pass-through now where it's
accumulated so much sediment that now
just stuff is passing through it's not
really depositing much behind the dam
anymore and so one thing that's happened
that you know Bob Hirsch reported is
that there's been a change in the
concentration discharge relationship you
know for between flow and phosphorous
and so now you're getting much higher
concentrations of phosphorous for the
same flow so some of these larger storms
now are generating much higher
concentrations of phosphorous than they
did say in the past and so here's this
is Lee here you've got concentrations of
over two milligrams per liter coming out
where storms of similar magnitude in the
past when it produced such a high
concentration and work out of Johns
Hopkins has also shown kind of an uptick
in total p and this is largely explained
by particular phosphorous count
contribution there's also scour going on
behind the dam to is another issue
because it's full so you're seeing kind
of an uptick you had a decline here in
total phosphorous in all seasons really
a kind of Wingo at now just recently
they're starting to see an upward trend
in phosphorous release from from the dam
to downstream so it's starting to become
a source of phosphorus in part due to
scour perhaps due to dissolve p is still
actually going down so it's really a
particulate p phenomenon that's what's
going on behind the dam but kind of an
interesting story and there's a lot of
discussion in annapolis and elsewhere
about what to do about the kind of Wingo
I they had just released a report last
fall on whether they should dredge it or
not dredge it i think the recommendation
was to not dredge it and to leave it
alone but it is you know look going
forward something to probably consider
in terms of phosphorus management and
the challenges it represents so i'll
probably i'll close here which is some
emerging concerns and one that I thought
is probably most pressing from a
nutrient management standpoint is
is kind of the role of climate change on
hydrological hydrological connectivity
and phosphorus loss this is the FG
thirty-six watershed one of the sub
watersheds where we work and this just
shows the distribution of phosphorus
concentrations and soils from less than
50 on the web to greater than 400 parts
per million and so typically with the
foster syndics what we've done or one
approach has just been to try to get at
you know what's the contributing area
for different storms or different or
storms of different return periods and
so a real simple way is just to try to
come up with a linear distance a buffer
from the stream and say that's your zone
of risk and we've typically managed for
these frequently occurring one year to
year kind of storms new those the ones
were most concerned with they come
around most often and so if you did that
just for this particular watershed your
one year storm you draw a buffer you
know around the system like this and you
would say this is a zonal right you know
most actively going to protect you know
for phosphorous loss but recently with
these reports that have come out you
know there's been some really
interesting findings in terms of you
know we've seen this we booked their own
data there's a there's a bin for example
a 71 percent increase in your current
such extreme rainfall events from 58
1958 to 2012 so we're getting more
extreme rains were you know you know
flooding there's been an increase in
river flooding that's in you know across
the US but most prominently you know
we've seen upticks in the Northeast and
so in FG thirty-six this is just looking
at Tropical Storm Lee as an example and
perhaps it's an extreme case but I
picked the most extreme because it'd
probably help tell the story a little
bit but the peak discharged in ft 36
with 53 cubic feet feet per second for
tropical storm lee that equates to about
a return period of 73 years for that
storm and so a storm that occurs you
know with that kind of frequency you
know this is you draw a hundred meter
buffer for a five year storm you get
maybe a ten year storm is 150 meter
buffer and beyond that you're kind of
almost the entire watershed is at that
point a critical source area I mean
that's not the city entire watershed is
generating
off but you know one would presume that
anyone any of these areas could
conceivably contributing bosphorus and
so if these storms are going to become
more frequent at all if there's if
there's any tendency for these storms
become more common than I think you know
in terms of nutrient management one
concern is just you know how can we
manage how do we manage for these kinds
of events they're also the ones that
move the most P and if you look at
phosphorus loss just on in w38 Harry
piankhi was famous for saying that you
know it's one or two storms in a year
that would you know produce the majority
of your phosphorus loss so it's if it
storms like this then you know how to
you know how do we how do we manage you
know for these kinds of events and so
with that gonna get about ten minutes
left so it's probably good that I'm
summarizing basically in summary you
know that for the sloped areas it's the
hydrologically active areas that drive
phosphorus transport you know and those
are the areas that we most are
interested in managing and protecting
you on the lowlands where our primary
concern is artificial drainage and the
role of drainage and connecting
phosphorus sources to receiving waters
and ways to manage and mitigate you know
you know the phosphorus moving from the
landscape to the stream fosters
transports in rivers is largely
event-driven and a large that the
majority that's occurring in storms and
you know changes in the frequency of
extreme events i would say represent an
area of emergent concern you know that
those of us are dealing in nutrient
management should be looking into and
with that i'm done i really appreciate
your time and your attention and I'll
take any questions that you guys would
have
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu